what's up everyone today yeah you
guessed it I'm going to work on the Main
Street yet again yeah this is still
going to go on for quite a bit and I do
need to apologize about this video at
least that's what I feel like because
this is really one of those instances
which is something that I talked about
when I just started this new park is the
fact that for this new park I kind of
went to focus on getting the park rights
and you probably know that most of this
is actually live streamed and I do mess
around with things even though most of
the times when I try new things I always
want to open a new park file and mess
around with certain things that I can do
so that the time lapse doesn't end up
being an experimentation fest with this
building there were just a couple of
things that I had to redo and I had to
take a quite a while to actually get
them right so it didn't result in the
best time-lapse ever but I think I do
kind of like the building in the end so
that's pretty good I guess you'll see
that in the end one thing is though
whenever I just let my perfectionistic
tendencies go lose it just happens
sometimes you get these time lapses in
which I place things and then remove
them has just happened with the arches
and stuff but basically what I'm
building today is it is a bit of a more
standard American Main Street building I
figured I could do this just to get that
type of theme into this Main Street and
the one thing that I'm not so sure about
actually is whether I want to keep the
Main Street exactly like this because
okay basically for each episode that I'm
releasing I'm becoming more certain
about the themes that I want to do in
this park which is actually a very handy
thing because as long as it takes to get
this matron it is really best to just
prepare yourself mentally and not in the
sense that you're mentally prepared but
in the sense that you know what kinds of
things you want to build an imp like
before I actually go built them and
having the time to think about that
while building the main street having
the time to communicate with loads of
people about the themes that I might
want to try and the sets that I can use
for that is really handy and at this
point I think I have a pretty clear idea
of what I want to do it's basically a
Eurasian theme throughout the park where
you travel through loads of countries
and actually kind of want to keep it
geographically correct in a sense so the
like the southern parts too
the East is going to be Spain and Italy
countries like that the northern part
will have the northern European
countries and then the eastern part of
the park we'll also have the Asian
themes but one thing I am is somewhat
worried about it's not really a problem
I guess it's the fact that this Main
Street is religious European it has
loads of mixes mixtures from loads of
different European countries but then
again it's all just European it doesn't
have any Asian buildings in it or Indian
stuff like that it's kind of what I'm
missing from this Main Street now I
think it is also a good thing because if
I would have put all those different
things into one Main Street it might
have looked like a bit of a mess but
then again I don't know if it's really
too good to have just one theme with
throughout the main street even if it's
just a mix of many different themes but
in any case I'm going to plan to keep it
like this well I might actually do is
when I have that main square in the
middle is then I add buildings of each
respectable theme that I'm gonna have in
each section of the park be like some
building on the main square so you can
actually see where you're going with the
themes and you can actually see all the
themes together in one place I think
that might actually be a kowai dia
though it would be kind of hard to
incorporate that and I was thinking of
Garland's first kind of like Disney does
it but let's do some small things done
not too certain about now when it comes
to the rides I am becoming more and more
certain about what kind of rides I want
to have I definitely want to have a B&M
dog machine I know that for the longest
time I was kind of undecided whether it
would be a PNM type machine or being an
invert but after seeing Baron 1898 and
other dog machines I just feel like I
really need something like that in my
Park I also want to have some dark ride
that is definitely confirmed actually I
just watched mystic machine by FF ICT
and todo de todo and I think that's his
name I always pronounce it wrong I'm
sorry if I pronounced that wrong but I
just suck at pronouncing stuff and loads
of other people I think also but that is
just an amazing dark ride I might
actually put that in the description I'm
probably I'm pretty much sure that I'm
going to forget that so if I forgot that
and you want to see it then just leave
the comments because yeah I'm an idiot
I always forget about stuff but I still
have the link somewhere saved in my ICT
3 favourites for those so and that
should be all good in any case I should
probably talk about this building as you
just saw I removed the spire which is
just one of those other instances of my
perfectionistic tendencies where I felt
like it didn't really work as well as I
wanted it to I tried to go for a battle
tower aspire but really it doesn't work
too well it does taken away a bit of the
European astute a Kawai that spire and
get a standard Main Street spire because
now I really feel like this building is
a bit American ish but still it has
those European touches to it anyway it's
just the classical building and general
neoclassical rather probably it's even
more modern although it's not posting
like shouldn't talk about that in any
case it's the type of standard Main
Street building but in a way that I
really like because this is the type of
Main Street building where you can just
add many pillars and all kinds of
decorations from the Main Street sets
and it's not a hard building to build it
you don't really take too many risks
it's always the same type of layout and
it's just fun to build because you can
mess with all the different details so
if you're building a Main Street a
building like this which is this pretty
wide has the same details throughout the
building but where you do mess with
loads of different details is always fun
to build but it always works pretty well
too I think though at first I wasn't too
sure how well this would work in this
particular Park but I think it works
alright this building on the side is
just built for random building next to
it because I needed something over here
so this is a bit of a not too very much
special building which kind of just has
the standard Main Street stuff going on
I guess I could call it actually I don't
know really what I could call it it's
one of those generic could be placed in
any city in Europe probably kind of
building
unlike the building on the other side on
the left side of this building I am
going to at least in a little bit of
time going to build another building and
that's going to be one of the first
places where I actually use my own
custom scenery for this park which is
definitely something that I want to try
and I've talked about this before but it
didn't really happen in any of the
episodes in which I talked about it but
yeah in this episode I am going to do
some custom scenery just some
simple custom scenery but I should
probably talk about that whenever I get
to that stuff
I don't know it's just something that I
felt like I could talk about probably
doing some stupid stuff over here but
this building just felt like a bit of a
generic building to really talk about
too much it's kind of a standard Main
Street building aside from the fact that
of course it is using those corner
stones which are from the Alpine set
which is something that I can really
recommend mixing various young guys set
almost always works because they just
have pieces that go well together
in general and especially with those
corner stones it feels to me like adding
those corner stones to Main Street
buildings rather than adding the pillars
that they come that they come with
almost adds like a bit of Europeana stu
the building the only thing that I am
really missing and that is something
that I definitely do want to make some
custom scenery for is the paintings on
the walls you might not be familiar with
this but with many European countries do
especially in places like Austria they
are too poor to actually get proper
decorations for their buildings so
instead they just paint on very fancy
stuff and that set is actually meant for
Spanish buildings and many people use it
for their roof tiles whatever kind of
theme that going for but the only issue
with that is if you want to have some
kind of rustic texture which is what I
am going for with this point is that
it's very bright and if you do make that
roof red if you want to have some red
roofs then you end up with the in-game
rct3 red which is more red and then I
would have liked it to be and this pets
after Ling set roofs is just a generic
ish Brown red colour shade I don't know
how to put it but it's more washed out
and as you can see also when you compare
it to the shyguys alpine village roofs
you definitely see that it's a bit more
realistic when it comes to the red tile
roofs because red tile roofs as red as
they are they aren't really completely
red there is a bit of brown in there and
it is not as bright as you'd imagine
them to be so even in the theme park I
would like my collars to be a bit rustic
so that's why I'm going for that now
this building over here I even even
talked about this yet this is just a bit
of a mirror in
of the building on the other side except
it has a bigger Tower which also took a
bit of messing around with it to get
right because I was a bit worried about
the spire but eventually with towers on
the side it works pretty well but this
building is honestly just a bit of a
side building it doesn't really serve
any function whatsoever it is not there
to look great or anything it's just
there to fill up the space and it was
really hard to get a really good looking
building in this space anyway because as
you may know the entrance building is
also a train station and even though I
haven't added the train itself yet I do
need to keep some space reserved for
that train and as the train station is
also quite narrow - just look quite
imposing but actually not be too big of
a building and there's not much space to
work with over here to actually place a
building plus I need some trees on the
other side so that you don't see this
building from the entrance so I'm going
to need a lot of things on a very small
space near the entrance over here so
really no room for a big building other
than just a very small Alpine building
which kind of fits the theme of the
entrance buildings well considering the
castle walls underneath it and the
alpine roofs and just in general the
stucco stuff over there that's going on
but yeah to be over a medieval building
guess it works pretty well with the
entrance building so I'm pretty happy
about this and then the case that's it
for this episode so thank you for
watching and I'll see you on the next
episode in which our yeah you guessed it
work a tiny bit more in the main street
so bye